[Music]
you're actually setting the internet on
fire people are digging what they call
the silver fox look you're the head like
GQ damn Steve Carell makes us mind gray
hair I am so sick of people just looking
at me for my physical attributes yeah
it's just genetic there's nothing I can
do nothing will prepare you for these
hot photos of Steve Carell yeah Oh
doesn't love this color look at him
Elvis hair would make you better
Steve Carell opened up to et at the
despicable Me premiere in LA about
becoming an internet sensation I'm
busting with pride like I that's very
nice what does your wife think when she
sees that she's like he's mine back off
she know she knows she does you know I
think she's hot and that's all that
matters guys are a fabulous couple
together there is a dance battle in this
film what is your go-to dance move the
moonwalk oh can I get a little bit of
the moonwalk
no don't go down just keep it up here
keep it up
oh yeah it's good smooth out and you
just imagine how good the feet work
[Music]
you